♪ Beef dessert, beef dessert ♪
- Are you still rolling?
- [Katie] Okay, Jasmine,
what are we doing today?
- I just finished watching
a clip from "Friends"
where Rachel makes this English Trifle,
and I've wanted to make
this for a very long time.
I've been very curious,
so I did some research to
see how we can make it.
We're gonna make it
because I want to find out
if it's like a comedy TV show punchline,
or if it's the real thing,
because Joey liked it.
- What's not to like? Custard? Good.
Jam? Good.
Meat? GOOD.
(Audience laughs)
- And I think I might be a Joey.
Then you guys said you
didn't want to try it
so I thought, well, we
should definitely do it.
So today, we will be making
the Thanksgiving Trifle
from "Friends" where Rachel messes it up
and it's a half a Trifle,
half a Shepherd's Pie.
Sounds pretty good. I'm excited.
- [Katie] Are you dressed
as Rachel right now?
- I am! You noticed?
(upbeat music)
We are gonna start by making the custard.
Rachel makes it from scratch.
I have a sauce pan over here.
I'm just adding in my milk.
Now I'm gonna add a pinch
of salt and my sugar.
Now we're just gonna whisk this together
until the sugar is melted.
And then we want to keep this warm,
we don't want it to come to a boil.
So while this is warming, I
am going to make my slurry.
I have some corn starch here
and I'm just going to add in my milk.
Just going to whisk this together.
So the slurry will help
thicken my custard.
This is just a very
simple classic custard.
Now we are going to separate some eggs.
Let's hope this goes well.
Or maybe you might catch a
Rachel moment right on camera.
- [Katie] You're very serious
right now what happened?
- Am I very serious?
- [Katie] Yes, you seem
very, very concentrated.
- You gotta be concentrated
when you're separating eggs
because...
Wow! That yolk is so much
bigger than the other one!
So, now I'm whisking up my egg yolks
and then we're gonna
temper it with my milk.
So with tempering the eggs,
it just means that you're slowly
bringing up the temperature
so it doesn't cook and
become scrambled eggs
because that was one of
my Rachel mistakes before.
Which is why I don't think she
really made it from scratch.
- I made from scratch.
- Now I'm adding my eggs,
my tempered eggs back into my milk.
And then we can move on to the next step.
So now that my egg is incorporated,
now I'm gonna add in my slurry.
I'm gonna slowly whisk
this for about five minutes
until it thickens up.
So the custard is done.
I've removed it from the heat,
and now we're gonna add in my butter.
And then one teaspoon of vanilla.
- [Katie] I think you're a Rachel.
- You think I'm a Rachael?
- [Katie] A little bit.
- I mean, I love her,
but I just don't think I am her.
When we're doing our taste
tests, I feel like a Joey.
All right. So my custard is done.
I removed it from the heat
and we're just gonna run this
through a fine mesh strainer.
So now I'm covering this
baby with saran wrap,
making sure to touch the custard,
to avoid getting that film on top,
and then I'm gonna let
it cool a little bit
before putting it in the
fridge for a few hours.
Now it's time to saute our
beef, peas, and onions.
Be right back.
I think this will taste
good. I have high hopes.
So now we're going to make
the beef part of this dessert.
It's supposed to be the Shepherd's Pie.
So this is where Rachel gets it wrong.
But you know what?
I think this mixture is
actually not that bad.
So I just added a splash
of some olive oil.
So if you don't know
what Shepherd's Pie is,
it's like a meat pie,
but instead of a pie,
it's more like a casserole.
And then it's topped with mashed potatoes.
There's really nothing to not
like about Shepherd's Pie,
unless you mix it with
ladyfingers and jam.
So I'm just going to saute these onions
until they're softened.
I'm adding some salt, some
pepper, 'cause why not?
All right, our onions have
softened a little bit,
so now we are gonna add in the beef.
- [Katie] Why do you like friends so much?
- Aw, well, it's a really
good show. I really like it.
But my mom, when she came to America,
she would watch Friends to learn English.
So, it has a very special
place in my heart.
This beef is looking absolutely lovely.
Now we're just going to
add in my frozen peas
and we're just going to fold this in.
All right, this beef is
looking good for our dessert.
I'm going to go gather
everything, get our custard,
and then we can get to assembling.
So I have some ladyfingers.
First, I'm going to line
them along the bottom.
Now I'm going to line the
side of the trifle dish.
Our first layer is in!
Next, we are going to go in with our jam.
I put it in a piping bag.
I'm trying to replicate the
little divots with the jam.
I actually don't think
that the meat and jam combo
will be that weird.
Jam is in, it's custard time.
Let's go in with this layer of custard.
- [Katie] Like, take out the beef,
do you think you'd like this now?
- [Jasmine] Yeah, if there was no beef,
this undoubtedly would be delicious.
Next layer. The raspberries.
The raspberries are gonna
get buried anyway so,
just making sure that
it has its own layer.
We're gonna go in with
another layer of ladyfingers
and it's time to go in with
the all-star ingredient, beef!
It actually doesn't look bad.
Now we're gonna go in with
another layer of custard.
Honestly, I feel pretty
good about this recipe.
- [Katie] Wow.
- [Jasmine] I'm not gonna lie.
It's banana time.
- [Katie] How do you
feel about the banana,
meat, custard combo?
- Actually, it's pretty common
to eat banana with some savory dishes,
or like all dishes for some cultures.
So it's not actually that weird to me.
Last layer, y'all. The
whipped topping. Oh yeah.
Let's just use the whole thing.
Oh, my gosh. This is beautiful.
- [Katie] Yeah.
- Hey!
You will eat it,
and you will like it!
All right, okay, I think we're done!
I'm gonna put this in the fridge,
let it sit for a few hours,
let the ladyfingers soften,
and then it's mealtime!
Can I get a woo?
- [Staff] Woo.
- First person we're
bringing in today is Adrian,
Tasty's production coordinator
and a Friends super fan.
Adrian has no idea this is happening.
So let's bring them in!
- I'm going to get Adrian.
Adrian.
- Yeah?
Hey.
- [Katie] Do you want to
come taste some "Friends"...?
- Yes!
- [Katie] What shirt are you wearing?
- How you doin'?
(Katie laughs)
- [Jasmine] When you're
ready, open your eyes!
- [Adrian] Whoa!
You have no idea how much
I've wanted to try this.
And I know, I think I know what this is.
The "Friends" Thanksgiving Trifle.
(Katie laughs)
- Mm.
- [Katie] You have three options.
Would you go to the balcony
and a bird takes this,
would you go to the bathroom
to watch yourself eat it in the mirror,
or would you down it like Joey?
Or does it taste like feet?
- I would definitely watch
myself eat it in the bathroom.
The reactions on the TV
show was very accurate.
- Here we go.
- [ Jasmine] You excited?
- I'm excited.
- [Jasmine] I think she likes it.
- What an adventure. The end
of it tastes like a burger.
Do I like this?
- [Jasmine] Okay, Katie,
you have three options.
- I'm gonna down it
like Joey. I'm shocked.
Kelly, you got to try this.
- This is one of my favorite episodes
I've ever watched from "Friends".
I have never wanted to try this though.
Mm-mm. I hate it.
- [Katie] You got three
options. Are you crying?
- Yeah. I'm going to the balcony.
It's going right over.
Hopefully into a trashcan
and not on someone's head.
But this has to go.
- So based on everyone's reaction,
I am taking away that
it's absolutely delicious.
It's really good, actually.
It tastes like french
fries in a milkshake.
I would down this like Joey.
I am downing it like Joey.
I am so happy I finally
got to satisfy my curiosity
after so many years.
This was actually really good.
So I now know, for certain,
the show is scripted because delicious!
As you saw all my friends enjoy.
If you're curious, you
guys should make it, too.
Take a picture. Tag us on
Instagram. We want to see.
Thanks, guys. Bye!
- [Man] Oh, yes.
(upbeat music)